Speaker 1: Here's a really interesting question.
If I ask you as a probable, you know, that
who's the typical David Pakman show viewer,
just on average, The David Pakman Show viewer
is a college educated.
Often making more than seventy five thousand
a year, mostly male, as many of these shows
are vaccinated, individual.
OK, the average David Pakman show viewer.
And of course, there's people of all kinds
in the audience.
I'm just giving you the demographic data we
have about how our audience skews the average
David Pakman show viewer.
If you ask them if I ask them, I'll ask you
right now who is to blame for the accelerated
rise in covid that we are seeing right now?
What what individuals most of you would say
the people who have chosen not to get vaccinated.
Now, of course, the Delta variant is more
contagious.
We're still understanding seasonality, decreased
waning efficacy of the vaccine after the eight
month period, all these different things.
But obviously, if everybody was vaccinated
by now, we wouldn't be seeing what we are
seeing right now, in particular hospitalizations
and deaths.
Now, let me ask you a different question.
If I asked you what or who would the average
unvaccinated person blame?
For the spike in covid, what would you say?
Well, there is a new Axios Ipsos poll and
it is absolutely insane.
Look at this.
So I'm putting the graph up on the screen.
I'm going to explain it to everybody, OK?
The answers in green are the answers of vaccinated
people, whereas the answers in red are the
answers of unvaccinated people.
So case in point, you go to the vaccinated
and you say, what's to blame for the rise
of covid and the new variants?
79 percent of the vaccinated say the unvaccinated
are to blame.
OK, that's that's backed up by science of
the vaccinated.
Also blame in descending order.
Donald Trump, conservative media.
No, they're not saying Trump is infecting
people, but it's the vaccine.
Hesitant and covid isn't serious rhetoric
of Trump conservative media doing the same
thing.
Foreign travelers in the US, Americans traveling
internationally, etc..
OK, the unvaccinated they immediately gravitate
to.
Foreign travelers in the US are the ones that
are to blame.
And then they go to mainstream media is to
blame.
And in fourth place, they have Joe Biden is
to blame and then they have the CDC is to
blame and then they have national public health
officials are to blame.
This is a completely backwards view.
The by the way, only nine point eight percent
of the unvaccinated blame themselves.
For what is going on right now, this is a
view which is based on why why do we blame
the CDC and the national public health officials?
Well, because they can't be trusted.
And Fauci was wrong about masks in March of
twenty twenty, and they're spreading lies
and gain of function research and all of this
different stuff.
Joe Biden is to blame.
Joe Biden has been trying to get people vaccinated.
Biden's to blame.
Why?
What are you talking about?
And then foreign travelers in the United States
seems to be the point of agreement of right
around, you know.
Twenty nine percent.
I'll put the numbers back up on the board.
Twenty nine percent of the vaccinated and
37 percent of the unvaccinated say foreign
travelers in the U.S. are to blame.
That's the one where these numbers are relatively
close.
This is just a world view that is totally
disconnected from what the science tells us.
So how do we deal with this?
These are not folks.
Listen, if you think mainstream media is behind
the explosion of Delta case infections and
hospitalizations and deaths, how are we going
to be able to have an even remotely substantive
conversation with you?
We're not going to be able to.
So then what do we have to do?
We probably have to do with some cities and
states and mostly cities are starting to.
Do you want to go to the movies?
You've got to be vaccinated.
You want to go to a restaurant and sit indoors.
You got to be vaccinated.
I'll talk on the bonus show today about my
my trip.
When I was in Germany, I went to a place that
had like an hour.
It was like a Biergarten German beer garden,
had a big outdoor area and an indoor area.
I went to the door.
The waitress comes up and says, if you want
to go inside, I need to see vaccination or
a negative test from today.
And it makes sense that that's what you would
start doing.
You've got to start making it more annoying
not to be vaccinated, because if you think
mainstream media is behind the rise in cases
and not the fact that we've only fully vaccinated
roughly half the country, then it's going
to be very hard to convince you otherwise.
Really, really difficult stuff.
And by the way, speaking of can't you just
fake a vaccine card?
Yeah, you can.
And that's actually the topic of today's voicemail.